[Music]
Afghan special forces were designed to
create Elite homegrown Commandos to
fight the Taliban they were trained by
NATO countries including Canada but
after Afghanistan fell in 2021 these
highly skilled operators found
themselves on Taliban kill lists
targeted for their extraordinary skills
and their history of hunting top Taliban
Commanders
now the former commander of afghan's
Special Forces says Russia is trying to
recruit his troops who fled to fight on
another Front Line the war in Ukraine I
said Ukraine and Russia is not your
country Global News spoke to three
ex-members of the Afghan Special Forces
including Lieutenant General Mohamed
Fareed Ahmadi they allege Russia through
intermediaries in Iran is trying to lure
Afghans to the war in Ukraine they are
receiving offers and some of them
already gone and most of them rejected
this recruitment letter circulating on
social media promises a monthly salary
of fifteen hundred dollars U.S from the
moment they enter Russia and a Russian
Federation passport it can be a hard
offer to Turn Down for former Afghan
Special Forces members living in Iran
illegally like this man Global News is
protecting his identity because of the
threat of deportation
my friend who was another former Special
Forces member went to fight for Russia
two months ago we haven't heard from him
since
the Afghanistan
the situation is harsh in Iran but if my
family and I returned to Afghanistan we
will be killed that's why I'm
considering fighting for Russia so is
another former Afghan Special Forces
member who spoke to Global News and
asked to remain anonymous
it's better to fight for Russia than let
my family star
with the conflict in Ukraine dragging
into its second year Moscow is desperate
for soldiers the Kremlin is relying on
Mercenaries like the Wagner group and
releasing convicts to take up arms right
now the the popularity for the war is
domestically is starting to decline a
British intelligence report says Russian
military recruiters are targeting
Central Asian migrant workers in Russia
to serve in Ukraine at mosques and
immigration offices the Ukrainian
Canadian Congress says it's another sign
the Russian armed forces are running out
of people willing to fight Russia is
trying to exploit
poverty in other parts of the world when
asked by global news about the
allegations the Russian Embassy said it
had no information on this topic the
former Afghan Special Forces members we
spoke to say they don't want to fight
for Russian forces but say they feel
abandoned by Western governments
including Canada the Canadian government
will not allow Afghan Special Forces to
come here as part of ottawa's refugee
pledge so the former soldiers are
running out of options
Taria esri Global News Ottawa